[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous et
bonne année 2024 on va continuer de
donner du sens à l'actualité avec les
journalistes de la rédaction de Public
Sénat avec nos chroniqueurs nos
éditorialistes nos invités experts
l'objectif vous le savez tous les jours
à 18h et 22h c'est de vous proposer des
clés de compréhension des crises que
nous traversons ici en France et dans le
monde et ce sont justement deux
actualités fortes que je vous propose
pour commencer cette année d'abord ce
suspense politique qui aura marqué la
journée du 8 janvier le Président de la
République a reçu ellizabeth borne à
l'Élysée cet après-midi Emmanuel Macron
a sans doute décidé de donner ou de
tenter de redonner du souffle à son
second quinena qui pour la remplacer
quel serait l'équilibre d'un éventuel
nouveau gouvernement comment repartir de
l'avant avec la même configuration au
Parlement on répondra à toutes ces
questions dans une minute avec vous
l'avez vu beaucoup de conditionnel et
puis dans notre seconde partie
d'émission on se demandera si le conflit
entre Israël et le Hamas pourrait
s'étendre à d'autres pays de la région
il s'agit d'un conflit qui pourrait
facilement se métastaser provoquant
encore plus d'unsécurité et de
souffrance pour éviter l'escalade le
secrétaire d'État américain anony
blinken est au Proche Orient Liban Iran
Syrie Turquie ces pays pourrai-il entrer
dans le conflit peut-on au contraire
assister à une nouvelle trêve pour
libérer les otages on en débat dans 45
minutes mais d'abord le récit de cette
journée où le sort d'Élisabeth borne
s'est joué avec Jérôme Rabier toujours
pas de fumée blanche à l'Élysée malgré
une accélération des consultations et
rumeurs sur le remanement pour la
deuxième fois en de jours Elisabeth band
s'est rendue cet après-midi au palais
présidentiel où elle est restée près
d'une heure en tête à-tête avec le
président de la République et depuis
silence radio le temps est comme
suspendu pour le gouvernement mais dans
la majorité les pronostics vont bon
train pour l'allié du modème François
Baayou il est nécessaire de tourner la
page ellisabeth borne donc comme il y a
forcément une nouvelle période qui
s'ouvre que vous savez bien pour
l'instant l'agenda de cette période
n'est pas fixé alors oui je pense qu'il
est légitime qu'il y ait du
renouvellement il défend en privé le nom
de Julien de Normandie macroniste
historique et ancien ministre de
l'Agriculture lors du premier quinquena
d'autrre avance le nom de Sébastien
Lecornu actuel ministre des armées mais
l'actualité internationale chargé
pourraitinciter à la stabilité un statut
co également revendiqué par Bruno Le
Maire qui souhaite rester à son poste
pour ce qui concerne l'économie et les
finances la
stabilité la stabilité dans cette
période de grand bouleversement a
beaucoup de vertu le nom de Gabriel Atal
est également cité pour succéder àabeth
born minist ministre de l'éducation
nationale pourrait être propulsé à
Matignon mais sa popularité dans les
sondages peut aussi être un handicap
Emmanuel Macron revendique en effet
d'être le seul maître à bord et ce
remanement lui redonne sa place de
faiseur de roi pour les opposition c'est
même le principal problème j'ai un scoop
pour vous je connais le nom du premier
ministre vous aussi d'ailleurs
uel Macron et son ministre des Affaires
étrangères ce sera aussi Emmanuel Macron
et son ministre de la Défense ce sera
EMU Macron son ministre de la Culture ce
sera Emmanuel Macron Emmanuel Macron
pourrait aussi créer la surprise en
conservant ellisabeth borne à Matignon
et attendre de futures échéances comme
les élections européennes ou les Jeux
Olympiques pour choisir son 4e Premier
ministre depuis
2017 vous l'avez compris à l'heure où je
vous parle en cette fin d'après-midi
c'est encore le temps des hypothèses et
donc un exercice difficile pour mes
invités laurose nerve bonsoir directrice
du cercle de réflexion destin commun
Jean gar bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
historien président du Comité d'histoire
parlementaire et vous publiez jours
heureux quand les Français rêvaient
ensemble aux éditions Paillot Mathieu
souquier bonsoir et bienvenue consultant
essayiste spécialisé en sciences
politiques et Mathieu croissantaliste
politique à Mathieu et bonne année à
toutes et à tous merci d'être là pour
redémarrer l'année en direct sur sur
notre antenne on va se placer dans
l'hypothèse d'un remanimement qui est
quand même la plus probable en cette fin
d'après-midi quels sont les enjeux d'un
Reman pour Emmanuel Macron pourquoi
pourrait-il se lancer dans cet exercice
compliqué
laurenceerveau alors il y a à y gagner
il y a à y perdre ce qu'il y a à y
gagner pour Emmanuel Macron c'est
évidemment de tourner la page le plus
vite possible de cette année 2023 qui a
été secoué qui a été chahuté et
notamment de cette dernière séquence à
quelques jours de la fin de l'année avec
l'adoption de cette loi sur une
migration qui a étit particulièrement
douloureuse et et qui a mis le Parlement
à feuill àang et en même temps si il
grille une carte trop vite il il disons
que il en aura moins à jouer dans les
mois qui viendront et notamment
l'échéance des élections européenne en
juin 2024 qui est périlleuse pour lui et
pour son camp et après laquelle il
pourrait avoir besoin justement de
relancer son quinquena et en fait le
fait de remagier dès maintenant pourrait
quasiment donner l'impression que on est
sur une défaite on est sur un un moment
presque comme une défaite électorale en
fait alors que ce n'est finalement pas
le cas donc voilà tout dépend du SIG
qu'Emmanuel Macron veut donner
aujourd'hui alors il y a déjà un signal
et alors ça va vraiment être le jeu de
cette fin
d'après-midi c'est Elsa dariola la ré la
rédactrice en chef pardon Elsa de de
cette émission qui vient de me le
signaler dans cette oreillette magique
Emmanuel Macron vient de tweeter il
remercie Elisabeth Bor donc il y a déjà
une certitude c'est qu'on va avoir un
nouveau Premier ministre et que
Élisabeth borne aura donc passé 20 mois
à à matigon les termes qu'il emploi il
la remercie merci
madame la la première ministre chère
Élisabeth borne il parle de son courage
de son engagement il parle d'elle comme
d'une femme d'État et il termine en
disant de tout cœur merci bon il y a
déjà cette info qui qui est assez c'est
bien on est on est assez heure
généralement un premier ministre REM sa
démission quand mê la Constitution
prévoit que c'est le premier ministreion
qui s'est passé cet
après-midi on peut communiquer
d'habitude sur la remise de la démission
et puis ensuite le président de la
République remercie
chaleureusement le Premier ministre tout
ça é quand même c'est étonnant ouais et
on n'est pas à l'abri dans quelques
minutes de d'avoir le nom du successeur
ce sera peut-être une femme mais sans
doute un homme ENF d'ailleurs pourquoi
pas on verra bien mais on est au jeu des
hypothèses je dis ça parce que ça fait
des heures qu'on a tous le nom de
Gabriel hatal le ministre de l'éducation
nationale en tête là aussi on va rester
prudent peut-être un mot sur le timing
tiens je veux bien vous entendre
làdessus jeangaric parce que pourquoi le
faire maintenant on est à 6 mois de la
prochaine échéance électorale les
élections européennes bon d'abord c'est
un ride sacrificiel de la 5e République
h voilà safie un premier ministre mais
si on sacrifie un premier ou une Premier
ministre en l'occurrence c'est pour
faire quelque chose d'autre et pour
faire quelque chose de mieux et donc le
choix du timing aujourd'hui me semble
assez risqué pour moi je je parlerai
d'un volontier d'un kitou double parce
que s s'il advient que le nouveau
Premier ministre et un gouvernement
qu'on nous dit resserré donne
véritablement une nouvelle impulsion qui
serait articulé sur ce rendez-vous avec
les Français dont parlait Emmanuel
Macron et que salut permettent de
d'aller en conquérant vers les élections
européennes alors on dirait voilà une
opération réussie mais ce cette cette ce
Paris là me semble très très risqué
parce que ce qui semble plus
vraisemblable c'est que ce confirme la
victoire du rassemblement national aux
élections européennes et que donc le
nouveau ou la nouvelle premier Premier
ministre on sait jamais que le nouveau
Premier ministre soit déjà dévitalisé
rés d'emblé c'est-à-dire que tout le
reste du quinquena se ferait sous le
signe de l'échec de celui qui était la
dernière carte du président alors à
moins qu'il y a un nouveau remanement 1
an avant l'échéance ce qui peut toujours
arrivé c'est c'est déjà arrivé sous sous
François Hollande mais voilà on on est
là dans une prise de risque qui me
semble quand même un peu inconsidéré
alors en même temps vous avez
semble-t-il 2 tiers des Français qui
souhaitent qu'on se débarrasse
deéisabeth Bor mais en réalité oui on
peut voir ce sondage d'ailleurs 66 % des
des Français selon jod ça backbon
consulting pour Le Figaro publié le 4
janvier dernier c'est tout récent qui
souhaitait le départ de la première
ministre mais ce sont les mêmes qui
souhaiteraient surtout le départ de
d'Emmanuel Macron il faut pas se le
cacher isisabeth borne comme une bonne
première ministre collaboratrice de la
5e République elle a fait la politique
de d'Emmanuel Macron d'ailleurs elle l'a
plutôt fait comme un bon petit soldat
donc très franchement on se demande si
là le timing est le bon parce que on
aurait compris après des élections
européennes plus ou moins raté qu'on
refasse partir la machine un nouveau
souffle aujourd'hui ça me paraî un peu
étonnant Mathieu sou votre avis pourquoi
Emmanuel Macron prend cette décision
d'pr alors à contrario rien ne serait
pire que d'avoir encore une séquence de
6 mois qui nous mène jusqu'aux
européennes qui soit aussi calamiteuse
que l'année 2023 qu'on a traversé il y a
peut-être encore quelque chose à sauver
en vue des européennes c'est sans doute
cette
der plus que ça les sondages ne sont que
des sondages mais ce que disent
précisément les sondage c'est que depuis
depuis l'été dernier l'écart qui n'était
que de 4
pointsou RN et les listes de
renaissance c'est fait fait plus que ça
croître il est aujourd'hui de 12 points
donc on voit bien que la tendance est
très très dure et donc il y avait
quelque chose il y avait quelque chose à
rendiquer alors encore une fois Emmanuel
Macron sort très affaibli de l'année
2023 alors globalement il est dans une
une séquence affaiblie parce que réélu
parce que pas pas candidat à sa
succession dans 3 ans parce que l'usure
du pouvoir parce que tout ça mais
l'année 2023 a été très rude et son
autorité a été effectivement mise à mal
son autorité à lui plus sa majorité et
donc il a besoin de se renforcer
incontestablement mais ce que disait
dans sa lettre de démission ça ça tombe
à l'instance no confrères de la FP
ellisabeth borne juge je la cite hein
plus que jamais nécessaire de poursuivre
les réformes c'est quand même ça l'enjeu
de de ce remanement aussi Mathie sou euh
oui alors il y a une identité politique
il y a une autorité politique à
réaffirmer il y a une identité politique
aussi à réaffirmer en tant que
réformateur président réformateur et
réformateur jusqu'au bout il y a un
remanimement ça marche et ça fonctionne
même quand c'est du kit tout double
effectivement si ça permet de redonner
de l'élan une impulsion politique à un
président de la République mais Raphael
Gman disait tout à l'heure quelque chose
de tout à fait sensé nous n'avons jamais
été aussi loin aujourd'hui
qu'aujourd'hui de l'esprit des
institutions c'estd que le le Premier
ministre qui détermine et qui conduit la
politique de la nation jamais sous
Emmanuel Macron précisément jamais aussi
peu que sous Emmanuel Macron était si
différent avec Nicolas Sarkozi
euh qume qui nommait son premier
ministre voà c c Fran François Fillon
avait été à de multiples reprises quand
même ministre il avait une expérience
politique il avait y compris un encrage
local qui lui donnait quand même une
légitimité que aucun des premierers
ministres d'Emmanuel Macron Nura jamais
on voit s'afficher pendant que vous
parlez j'ai donné les termes essentiel
mais le le le tweet donc qui nous a
annoncé officiellement
le la démission de d'Élisabeth borne
votre travail au service de notre nation
chaque jour exemplaire vous avez mis en
œuvre notre projet avec le courage
l'engagement et la déterm tion des
femmes d'état de tout cœur merci Mathieu
oui pour qu'un remanement soit réussi il
faut qu'il y ait un moment un casting et
un sens politique et que c'est possible
les trois cas soient coché et qu'elles
soi aligné moi je pense plutôt comme
Mathieu souer que le moment il est
plutôt bien choisi parce que même si
l'exécutif s'en défend il y a une crise
il y a une crise politique majeure au
terme de cette année 2023 qui a été
compliqué il y a une crise dans la
majorité qui pour l'instant a été
contenu mais il y a quand même une crise
dans la majorité et enfin il y a le
scrutin européen et donc une bataille sa
SEM mène ils ont ils ont en tête le
souvenir de 2019 où la liste
présidentielle était partie avec des
points de retard jusqu'à ce qu'Emmanuel
Macron lui-même s'en mê vous vous
souvenez c'est lui qui avait fait
campagne qui av c'est lui qu'on voyait
sur les affiches c'est lui qui avait
fait des des grandes alors c'était pas
des meetings mais c'était des des
grandes rencontres avec les citoyens
pour faire campagne donc le moment il me
paraît plutôt bien choisi le casting on
voit que c'est compliqué on va y revenir
mais avec tous les noms qu'on a vu
apparaître qui n'ont parfois euh aucun
aucun rapport les uns avec les autres
donc c'est c'est toujours étonnant et
puis ensuite il y a le sens politique je
rejoint Mathieu quel est le sens
politique de cette affaire quand on
remanie on peut vouloir élargir sa
majorité on peut vouloir faire venir un
allié on peut vouloir faire venir un
poids lourd c'estàd quelqu'un qui a une
autonomie politique de penser et qui est
capable de déterminer de conduire la
politique de la nation comme le prévoit
notre Constitution mais là pour
l'instant on voit pas très bien le sens
politique de cette affaire il est le
sens il est comme vous comme vous l'avez
dit dans la tête du président mais dans
la tête et dans sa tête seule c'est
qu'il y a pas d'écrit il y a pas de
livres il y a pas de on sait pas ce que
c'est que le macronisme lui seul sait
quelle coloration quel sens quel quelle
direction il veut donner à la fin de son
quinqué là et ça pour le coup si on
prend quelqu'un d'interchangeable pour
mener cette politique là ça ne peut être
qu'un exécutant ouai alors on se posera
effectivement la question de la
personnalité de la marge de manœuvre de
du futur premier ministre oui ou non
Gabriel Atal pour l'instant on n' pas la
réponse on verra bien mais peut-être si
on reste sur le le l'enjeu le l'intérêt
ce que ce qu'un remanimement peut
apporter à un quinquena on peut
s'appuyer Laurence deerveau sur une
étude que vous avez réalisé avec votre
cercle de réflexion ving tank destin
commun sur le le sentiment de cohésion
des Français c'est intéressant sur la la
la division 70 % des Français
considèrent que notre pays est divisé si
on compare aux Allemands ou aux
Britanniques c'est beaucoup plus que les
Allemands qui sont à 50 % les
Britanniques à 54 % est-ce qu'il est pas
là l'enjeu principal reconstruire la
confiance tout à fait c'est d'ailleurs
comme ça que François Baayou l'a décrit
hier je le cite il a dit l'enu
aujourd'hui c'est de reconstruire une
confiance qui s'est hélas délité entre
les Français et l'État entre entre les
Français eux-mêmes et même si j'ose dire
entre les Français et la France c'est
tout à fait juste on a en France un
déficit de de confiance en nous-mêmes de
un déficit de fierté également de fierté
nationale qui s'illustre notamment par
ce chiffre que vous venez de citer donc
je le répète le sentiment de division
est-ce que notre pays est uni ou est-ce
qu'il est divisé 70 % des Français
répondent dans le sens de la division
contre eux seulement 50 et 54 % des
Britanniques et des Allemands pour la
même question il s'agit seulement d'une
perception alors que les Britanniques
sont passés par le brexit qui a
profondément déchiré le pays voilà et
puis si on si on tire ce fil on voit que
sous l'angle de la cohésion également
euh le de la confiance également pardon
la confiance évidemment dans les
institutions dans les politiques est
profondément
dégradée avec des écarts tout de même
entre l'exécutif et les élus locaux qui
continuent à davantage tirer les les
leur épingle du jeu la confiance dans le
président de la République est à 28 % ça
c'est décembre 2023 la confiance dans le
gouvernement à 27 euh et dans dans les
députés à 32 et les maires à 56 voil on
voit que la première institution peut on
peut les voir ces chiffres c'est la
police absolument le la question dans
quelle mesure avez-vous confiance dans
voilà il y a la list la police le ma
député la police voil les chiffres les
plus hauts ce
sont les proches les Français font
toujours confiance à leurs proches en
premier lieu mais aussi les médecins les
petits commerçants l'armée la poli les
enseignants et les voisins voilà donc en
fait les figures qui représentent
l'ordre l'autorité la science malgré
tout et surtout la proximité mais toutes
les institutions politiques sont très
bas les partis politiques sont bon
derniers avec 16 % de confiance
seulement et le président plafonne un
peu parce que ce ce chiffre était très
proche il y a 2 ans ouais alors vous
avez cité François Baayou ti je je ça ça
m'inspire une question que je vais vous
poser jean-gar à quel point il pèse un
François baayrou là dans le choix du du
du Premier ministre dans un contexte de
majorité fragile évidemment je suis pas
dans le secret des dieux mais il faut
quand même comprendre que François Baou
est celui qui avait permis la première
élection de d'Emmanuel Macron en lui
apportant les quelques pourcentage de
voix qui était indispensable qu'il pèse
parce qu'il y a un groupe modem à
l'Assemblée dont on a vu d'ailleurs
qu'il commençait à formuler des
critiques plus que des critiques au
moment de la loi immigration donc c'est
quelqu'un qui au-delà même de son rôle
de conseiller de de visiteur du soir
comme on dit c'est-à-dire qui est assez
présent auprès d'Emmanuel Macron c'est
quelqu'un qui qui a un poids politique
indéniable maintenant sur le choix du du
Premier ministre les bruits qu'on a pu
entendre nous disait par exemple que il
se serait opposé à la désignation et on
verra peut-être qu'il n'a pas eu de gain
de cause mais de de de Sébastien le
Cornu qu'il jugeait trop identifié à
droite euh bon est-ce que est-ce que
c'est véritablement une influence eff
efficace pardon ça c'est compliqué de de
le dire mais je reviens quand même moi
sur tout à l'heure je ne disais pas je
je répète que le moment était pas
forcément le bon mais simplement ça va
être c'est un Paris très très risqué que
de le faire maintenant c'est ça que je
veux dire et que ça serait peut-être à
mon sens plus cohérent et moins risqué
de le faire un peu plus tard après les
élections européennes bon voilà on est
dans ce dans dans ce cas de figure et
pour revenir à à ceux qui influent sur
Emmanuel Macron ce qu'on nous dit aussi
c'est que il écoute de moins en moins et
qu'il a plutôt la tentation d'aller
justement vers vers ses proches franis
Baou c'est un pouvoir de nuisance bloque
des routes plutôt qu'il me propose des
nom on se souvient que il avait bloqué
la route de Catherine Vautrin qui était
pressentie pour matigon en juin 2022 et
que du coup ça avait abouti à la
nomination d'Élisabeth borne bon allez
on se pose là on va rentrer quand même
alors là encore on va être dans le dans
les conditionnels et dans les hypothèses
et vous nous en excuserez j'en suis
certain cette hypothèse
Gabriel avant peut-être de se concentrer
sur la personnalité du ministre de
l'éducation nationale Mathie souquier à
quel point le choix du Premier ministre
et peut-être aussi de la nouvelle équipe
gouvernementale peut nous donner à nous
puisquon se posait la question du
macronisme du cap de ce que ça signifie
des indications sur le cap qu'Emmanuel
Macron veut donner à cette deuxème
moitié de de second quinquena dans un
remanimement vous avez effectivement un
enjeu d'autorité d'élan politique or un
président de la République ne se
renforce pas s'il se choisit un premier
ministre faible et encore une fois
jusqu'à présent il avait plutôt fait le
choix de premier ministre faible et
quand le premier Premier ministre a
cessé d'être faible précisément il a
commencé à devenir problématique donc en
tout cas on voit bien que en terme de
casting c'est vers cela que Emmanuel
Macron aurait plutôt envie de pencher le
deuxième élément précisément c'est celui
de la cohérence c'est celui du Cap
politique et là pour le coup il a bien
une alternative c'est que soit il en
revient au macronisme version 2017 de en
même temps de politique équilibrée et
avec un état d'esprit ou une philosophie
disruptive soit précisément il est
cohérent avec le choix qui a été fait en
2022 ce n ce n'est plus le macronisme de
2017 mais c'est celui c'est celui de
2022 qui est beaucoup moins équilibré
beaucoup plus tourné vers la droite on
se souvient que encore une fois en 2022
il avait préomté le programme de Valérie
pcrress et siphoné son électorat et que
depuis avec la avec la réforme des
retraites et avec la loi imigration on
s'est très largement déporté vers la
droite donc soit il fait un choix de
cohérence en se réalignant sur 2017 soit
il fait un choix de cohérence en restant
aligné sur le dernier choix de 2022 et
donc derrière évidemment la personnalité
choisie pour Matignon H dit quelque
chose de la cohérence à don du cap à
privilégié si c'est Gabriel àal euh
Laurence dener que ça ça qu'est-ce que
ça dit de du du choix présidentiel il
est allé chercher le plus populaire de
la bande en quelque sorte là je suis
volontairement simplificateur mais il y
a un peu de ça mais tout à fait d'abord
peut-être qu'Emmanuel Macron déjourait
un petit peu les pronostics parce que
ces derniers jours tout le monde a dit
il va choisir un de ses proches de la
première heure et les noms qui sortaient
en priorité étaient plutôt des
personnalités relativement discrètes
Sébastien lecnu et Julien de Normandie
le choix de Gabriel hatal ce serait le
choix de la jeunesse il n'a même pas 35
ans alors pour un président de la
République qui a accédé à la tête de
l'État à 39 ans c'est peut-être la
normalité toujours est-il que c'est ce
serait le premier le plus jeune premier
ministre de la 5e République ce serait
aussi à l'évidence le choix de la
popularité et donc le le choix de de re
de repolitiser cette fonction de la
renforcer ce qui n'a pas été ses choix
jusqu'ici bien sûr popularité on sait
que Gabriel Atal est devenue en décembre
la personnalité politique la plus pop en
France il a doublé Édouard Philippe dans
les sondages il est une des rares
personnalités politiques qui vraiment
imprime auprès d'une très grande
majorité des Français ce serait aussi
dans une certaine mesure le choix de
l'autorité Gabriel Atal est un petit peu
à 360 degr sur les sujets depuis qu'il a
été porte-parole du gouvernement donc il
a la capacité à tenir les poids lourds
du gouvernement qui sont en face de lui
ce serait aussi sans doute je pense le
choix de la combativité face à un un
Jordan Bardella qui est très jeune lui
aussi qui a un petit peu son alt
et qui est déjà lancé depuis plusieurs
mois dans la course pour les européennes
donc mais ce serait en en quelque sorte
une façon de pour Emmanuel Macron
d'acter le fait que son avenir politique
à lui est terminé qu'il ne se
représentera pas en 2027 quoi qu'il
arrive et que donc il laisse plus de
place désormais à son premier ministre
jean- gar oui il y a encore autre chose
pour Gabriel Atal à mon sens et
jeouscris tout ce qui a été dit qui est
le travail qu'il a effectué au ministère
de de l'éducation nationale et ce fameux
rendez-v vous avec les Français dont on
nous parle ce
réarmement civique ou pédagogique dont
on nous parle aujourd'hui qui pourra
être qui pourrait donner un sens à la
fin du quinquena en tout cas moi je
pense que à propos de cette division des
Français et de cette de ce renouveau du
de du du collectif et du sens civique ça
pourrait être un combat et Gabriel Attal
par rapport au combat qu'il vient de
mener au ministère de l'Éducation
nationale il serait en cohérence avec ce
type de d'engagement autour d'une je le
répète d'une S sorte de refondation
civique alors je sais pas quelle quelle
forme ça ça pourrait prendre il pourrait
être le le le Persin jidouan le gros
problème c'est que en brûlant comme ça
Gabriel hatal et peut-être en lui
brûlant les ailes au moment des
élections européennes ce serait pas
forcément rendre un grand service par
rapport à sa carrière personnelle ouis
justement Mathie suer est-ce que ça
signifierait pas de fait parce qu'il y a
un autre défi pour Emmanuel Macron c'est
de trouver une tête de liste pour pour
le parti Renaissance aux élections
européennes est-ce que si c'est un
Gabriel ou ou ou ou quelqu'un d'autre
d'ailleurs on sait pas encore on n pas
encore le nom du successeur d'Élisabeth
borna à matigon est-ce qu'il devient pas
de fait tê de liste de la majorité pour
les européennes
en tout cas je pense qu'il incarne assez
bien les choses alors ce qui est sûr
c'est que les deux noms qui bruissaient
depuis quelques jours Sébastien le corn
et nor merci Julien de Normandie n'urait
eu en peut-être l'un des deux sera-t-il
à Matignon dans quelques heur mais je
doute si c'est le cas en fait que ça ait
le moindre effet dans l'opinion en
revanche je pense que précisément le
choix de Gabriel Atal ne serait pas sans
effet dans l'opinion donc de ce point de
vue là ellisabeth borne zéro effet Jean
Castex zéro effet avec Gabriel Atal
précis une attente en tout cas il y a un
coup politique incontestable à faire le
choix de Gabriel Atal plus qu'un coup
politique je pense qu'il y a encore une
fois une façon symbolique et implicite
de renouer avec l'esprit du macronisme
parce que c'est je pense le choix le
plus disruptif le moins attendu et le
plus risqué le plus risqué avec
évidemment en face le potentiel de
bénéfice le le plus élevé je pense que
par ailleurs en terme d' dn politique je
dirais que Gabriel Atal est peut-être
celui qui colle le mieux à ce que le
macronisme quand même est censé
incarneré il a un équilibre Gabriel Atal
est quelqu'un qui vient de la gauche et
qui a régulièrement répété qu'il venait
de la gauche et on a fait politiquement
quelque chose et en même temps on voit
bien que en particulier depuis qu'il est
rue de Grenelle il penche de plus en
plus à droite et dans les enquêtes
d'opinion s'il est populaire c'est parce
que précisément il séduit l'électorat de
droite mais donc cet équilibre là j'ai
l'impression que Gabriel Atal parmi tous
ceux qu'on a cité et celui qui
l'illustre l'incarne le mieux même met
la zizanie à gauche avec l'affaire de la
baaya enfin l'in absum alors on a une
certitude à cette heure c'est
qu'éisabeth born a remis sa sa démission
en ces termes d'ailleurs le confrère de
l'Agence France Presse nous nous nous
nous donne quelques détails de la lettre
de démission alors qu' il faut présenter
la démission de mon gouvernement je
voulais vous dire combien j'ai été
passionné par cette mission guidée par
le souci constant que nous partageons
d'aboutir à des résultats rapides et
tangibles pour nos concitoyens la
volonté du chef de l'État de nommer un
nouveau Premier ministre elle nous dit
je vous ai déjà cité cet extrait tout à
l'heure qu'il est plus que jamais
nécessaire de poursuivre les réforme on
va revenir en arrière le jour de sa
nomination de la passation de pouvoir
avec Jean Castex 16 mai 2022 il y a
presque 20 mois écoutez alors comme vous
l'imaginez je je suis évidemment très
ému ce soir et je ne peux pas m'empêcher
d'avoir une pensée pour la première
femme qui a occupé ses fonctions et d
Cisson et peut-être je voudrais dédier
cette nomination à toutes les petites
filles en leur disant allez au bout de
vos rêves et rien ne doit freiner le
combat pour la place des femmes dans
notre société allez on ouvre un chapitre
dans ce débat on va faire le le bilan de
du passage Elisabeth borne à Matillon
Matthieu peut-être d'abord pour démarrer
revenir sur cette phrase alors qu'il me
faut présenter la démission de mon
gouvernement oui et la volonté du chef
de l'État dit c'est pas la sienne c'est
écrit noir sur blanc et je le disais
tout à l'heure c'estd pas Emmanuel
Macron a communiquer avant elle sur la
remise de C démission d'habitude l'élisé
dit le Premier ministre a remise sa
déémission président de la République
qui que là on voit bien qu'on est dans
un dans un moment particulier pourquoi
parce que jusqu'au bout elle aura cru
peut-être en ses Chan ellisabeth borne
ses amis comme ses ennemis la disaient
usé fatigué abîmé et pourtant en un an
et demi ben elle a tenu elle a fait le
job pour une fonction autre
fonctionnaire qu'on disait si peu
politique elleait même fait preuve d'une
résilience hors norme je disais elle a
fait le job parce qu'elle a appliquer
sans rechigner la feuille de route pour
le moins mouvante d'Emmanuel Macron avec
des flous des virages à 180°gr parfois
des choses trappes aussi à son actif
elle a fait adopter une soixantaine de
textes on le sait en assumant sa
fonction de paratonire de l'exécutif et
puis à défaut d'être une fidèle
d'Emmanuel Macron avec lequel le courant
n'est jamais passé visiblement pas cet
après-midi non plus
remerciements chaleureux et ben elle
s'est montré d'une loyauté sans faille
alors si on regarde son passif
maintenant Elisabeth Bor n'ura pas
hésité à malmener un parlement parfois
ingérable il faut le dire à coup de
procédure inédite et quand même bien peu
consensuelle dont la plus célèbre et le
493 utilisé à 23 reprises puis surtout
la locataire de Matignon même si elle
s'est révélé parfois un peu politique
mais c'est quand même fait rouler deux
fois dans la farine par LR une fois
pendant les retraites une fois sur
immigration entraînant le pays quand
même dans le plus gros conflit social
qu'on a connu depuis 25 ans pour le
premier cas et plongeant sa propre
majorité au bord de la crise don voir de
l'implosion pour le second pourquoi
Emmanuel Macron décide finalement de
s'en séparer ben parce qu'en fait
c'était pas la bonne personne on voit
mal comment le président de la
République aurait pu on le disait tout à
l'heure lancer un nouvel élan
lancer un nouveau cap avec avec
ellizabeth borne pourquoi le camp
présidentiel a besoin d'un chef de
guerre on en parlait tout à l'heure pour
mener la bataille des européennes et
remontter son retard sur le RN isab
borne a des qualités mais ce n'est pas
forcément une chef de guerre et le
l'exécutif a aussi besoin d'un chef
d'orchestre pour apaiser la majorité
nouer qui sa de nouveaux accords
politiques au au fil des textes et puis
imposer son autorité au gouvernement là
encore ce sont des qualités que n'avait
plus je dirais ellizabeth borne pas
qu'elle n'a pas eu jamais mais qu'elle
n'avait plus aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on
peut dire pour conclure de la façon dont
il a allit traité sa première ministre
et ben c'est pas une très très belle
façon il faut le dire franchement
franchement pourquoi il a fait durer le
déplaisir comme ça pour se donner du
temps pour être le seul maître des
horloges pour pouvoir choisir qu'il
voulait ça c'est bien compréhensible
dokin avançait le scénario dont on
parlait de la faire durer jusque aux
européennes pour s'en servir de fusible
si le résultat n'était pas bon et
Matignon est un enfer on le sait mais la
façon dont le président aura traité sa
première ministre en multipliant les
injonction contradictoire ou impensible
vous vous souvenez des fameux 100 jours
pour élargir sa majorité il y a eu quand
même beaucoup de Ch comme ça et puis la
fragiliser quand même régulièrement il y
a 6 mois elle était déjà en suspens avec
un précédent remanement qu'elle avait
finalement réussi à à surmonter là de
nouveau elle était fragilisée moi je
trouve que ça restera dans les anales de
la maltraitance politique Laurence de
nerveau qu'est-ce que vous retenez des
presque 20 mois de d'Élisabeth barne à
Matignon le mot résilience qu'on qu'on
met à toutes les sauces mais qui
s'applique finalement pas mal à son à ce
qu'elle a mené commeti alors maintenant
que ça y est maintenant qu'on sait
qu'elle s'en va je trouve qu'on fait un
exercice très français on va tous
ensemble lui tresser des l'orriers alors
que tout le monde évidemment et 66 % des
Français on demandé son départ et CETA
oui elle va redevenir populaire assez
vite vous allez voir génord avec croiss
elle n'a pas démérité mais c'est ce que
jean-ar disait aussi tout à l'heure
c'éta un bon petit soldat alors
qu'aujourd'hui il nous faut un chef de
guerre c'est toute cette différence en
fait qui peut résumer ce qu'on retiendra
d'éisabeth borne je voudrais quand même
revenir sur un point c'est que on lui
attribue très souvent les stigmates de
ces nombreux 493 que vous venez de Rapp
sont-ils vraiment les siens c'est-à-dire
que est-ce que cette ce recours 493
n'était pas tout simplement inscrit dans
le résultat des élection législative
avec un parlement assez ingérable une
opposition de gauche menée par un
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui a théorisé la
conflictualisation permanente d'un côté
et de l'autre côté un rassemblement
national qui a multiplié par 10 le
nombre de ses sièges pour passer de 8 à
88 voilà éil simplement possible de
gouverner autrement et de de mener le
Parlement autrement c'est c'est on peut
en débattre mais en revanche il me
semble que la vraie rupture la vraie
cassure a plutôt été au moment de la loi
immigration où il n'y a pas eu de 493
mais il y a eu l'adoption d'un texte
avec beaucoup de mesures qui étaient
quand même sous la dictée du RN et avec
les voix du RN même si évidemment ces
voix ont été décomptés quelque peu
artificiellement le fait qu'Élisabeth
borne fasse passer tout ça si vous
voulez comme une lettre à la poste et
dès le lendemain dans les médias cherche
à minimiser un certain nombre de de
choses qui relevaient fondamentalement
d'un virage extrêmement abrupte même si
on peut considérer que cette loi
correspondait à ce que les Français
souhaitaient et cetera toujours est-il
que cette loi ne correspondait
absolument pas à la ligne du
gouvernement qu'il défendait qu'il
poussait depuis 1 an là c'est là plutôt
que que me semble-t-il était la vraie
cassure la vraie rupture et et là il il
y a une vraie question sur la
composition du futur gouvernement je je
je je me tourne vers vous Mathieu
souquier où va passer l'aile gauche quoi
l'aile gauche de de de la macronie
combien de ministres resteront qui
l'incarnera ça ça va être un vrai un
vrai équilibre à à analyser alors deux
choses là-dessus si c'est Gabriel Atal
quand même qui prend la suite
d'éliisabeth borne c'est un c'est plus
qu'un signal envoyé à l'elle gauche de
la macronie encore une fois même si rut
Grenel depuis 6 mois on voit bien quand
même que l'orientation de Gabriel Atal
était plutôt vers vers la droite malgré
tout c'est un signal positif envoyé à la
gauche par ailleurs je ne succomberai
pas à la tentation précisément de
tresser des laorriers à Elisabeth born
je note que elle venait de la gauche
elle a commencé sa carrière politique en
backofice au cabinet de Lionel Jospin
quand il était premier ministre et elle
s'est retrouvé quand même euh en tant
que Premier ministre à effectivement
porter deux réformes et lois qui l'ont
éloigné de ses bases à gauche la réforme
des retraites elle l'a manifestement
manifestement assumé sans le moindre
scrupule n'était pas une réforme de
gauche c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
et la loi immigration quand même là
aussi je je en terme encore une fois
quand même de colonne vertébrale de
colonne vertébrale et même de fidélité à
un certain nombre de valeurs je note que
celui qui fut son directeur de cabinet
pendant sa sa première année à Matignon
et qui était devenu ministre de la de la
santé et le seul à avoir démissionné en
disant cette fois-ci la ligne rouge est
franchie donc je ne sais pas en fait ce
que pense dans la vie ellisabeth borne
au au au bout de 20 mois de de présence
à matino en tout cas je note qu'elle a
commencé son parcours politique dans
l'entourage
de et galfini en étant salué par Marine
Le uite on se projette dans les dans
dans dans les réformes prévues cette
année un mot sur lesisabette bande moi
je seraiis un peu plus nuancé dans les
jugements qui sont portés là sur la loi
immigration et sur le
l'inflexion droitière de non pas
d'Élisabeth borne mais de de Gabrielle
Atal au ministère de l'Éducation est-ce
que la laïcité l'ordre républicain sont
des valeurs de droite bon on peut on
peut discuter sur Elisabeth borne je
peux pas rien dire de de de différent de
de de mes camarades effectivement on est
dans le les les résultats
institutionnels de cette
présidentialisation progressive de nos
institutions qui fait que le le
périmètre d'un Premier ministre c'est
aujourd'hui considérablement restreint
que les premier ministres de l'IRE
Macron ont accepté cette cette réduction
ce statut de premier collaborateur du du
président de la République que
lorsquédouard Philippe a voulu un peu
s'émanciper de cette contrainte il a été
prié de de s'en aller et que donc
Élisabeth borne ben elle a fait un petit
peu comme ses prédécesseurs ça n'a
d'ailleurs pas commencé il faut l'avouer
avec Emmanuel Macron mais cette dérive
progressive de la la fonction Prim
ministérielle et qui va jusqu'à ce
rituel du du sacrifice bon maintenant
est-ce que le le prochain juste est-ce
que prochain Premier ministre aura la
capacité justement de de résister à
cette présidence jupitérienne est-ce que
Emmanuel acceptera de laisser une place
au futur premier ministre c'est c'est B
c'est c'est ce dont on va parler vous
pouvez vous préparer parce que je vous
questionnerai là-dessus dans un instant
mais d'abord je propose à Steve Jourdin
de nous rejoindre sur ce plateau parce
qu'on va aussi grâce à grâce à Steve se
se projeter bonsoir Steve bienvenue
bonne année anné déjà sou
oui bah oui voilà on commence par par un
remement on aura au moins eu une info
c'est qu'Élisabeth Bor n'est n'est plus
premre ministre là on va se projeter sur
cette année les grands moments
politiques de 2024 à quoi peut-on
s'attendre le texte immigration vous en
souvenez oui il revient le texte il a
été adopté par le Parlement fin décembre
c'est cette fois autour du Conseil
constitutionnel de l'examiner les Sages
ont jusqu'au 26 janvier prochain
précisément pour rendre leur décision il
vérifie actuellement si le texte viole
ou non la Constitution d'ici là la
pression sur le gouvernement ne va pas
retomber 200 personnalités ont signé ce
weekend une tribune dans l'humanité et
mediaapart appelant un grand
rassemblement contre la loi ça sera le
21 janvier parmi les signataires on
trouve des syndicalistes comme Sophie
Binet des intellectuels comme Pierre
Rosenvallon ou encore des artistes il y
a notamment l'actrice Josiane balasco ou
encore l'écrivin Nicolas Mathieu alors
le calendrier parlementaire maintenant
il sera également chargé oui reprise des
travaux la semaine prochaine lundi 15
janvier ça va commencer très fort
l'Assemblée nationale se penche la
semaine qui suit le 24 sur l'entrée de
l'IVG dans la Constitution c'est une
réforme de la Constitution il faut donc
et bien que le Sénat adopte adopte ce
texte dans les mêmes termes qu'il soit
ensuite validé par un congrès réuni à
versaill on a déjà une date pour ce
congrès ce sera au début du mois de mars
autre grand rendez-vous politique c'est
la présentation de la loi sur la fin de
vie elle a été promise par Emmanuel
Macron l'été dernier elle a été
plusieurs fois repoussée le chef de
l'État de pourrait en dévoiler les
contours au début du mois de février
puis autres dossier sur la table Thomas
la disparition officielle des centrales
à charbon leur fermeture avait été
repoussé mais une loi devrait être
présentée dans les mois qui viennent
pour acter leur fin définitive le
gouvernement veut aussi inscrire dans la
loi la généralisation du service
national universel et faire voter une
loi agriculture d'ici à la fin de
l'hiver l'idée c'est notamment de
faciliter la construction des fameuses
mégaabassines pour stocker l'eau et puis
autre sujet ce matin brune le maire a
annoncé une loi sur l'attractivité
financière de la France
écoutez-le devenu la nation la plus
attractive pour les investissements
étrangers en Europe pour conforter cette
place je vous annonce qu'une loi sur
l'attractivité financière de la France
sera présenté au Parlement au printemps
2024 est-ce que ça voudrait pas dire que
Bruno le merire sera au printemps encore
minist encore à ber sera dans quelques
heures d'autres rendez-vous politiques
sont attendus dans les mois qui viennent
au mois de juin place évidemment aux
élections européennes le scrutin aura
lieu le 9 juin et puis cet été auront
lieu les très attendus jeuxx olympique
cérémonie d'ouverture prévue le 26
juillet ouais c'est aussi un événement
politique d'une certaine façon merci
beaucoup Steve Jourdain pour toutes ces
information Laurence de nerveau moi je
voudrais que il nous reste un peu moins
de 10 minutes là pour terminer ce ce
débat qu'on se concentre sur finalement
cet équilibre entre le Président de la
République et le Premier ministre à quel
point le quinena a a changé le peut-être
le centre de de gravité et et et nous
éloigne de plus en plus de ce qui était
l'essence de de la 5e République chez
chez ceux qui l'ont qui l'ont fondé
est-ce que la la crainte d'Emmanuel
Macron c'est de devenir un canard
boiteux pour reprendre l'expression de
de de la politique américaine qui soit
en incapacité de réformer c'est un peu
l'impression qu'on a eu depuis 18 mois
est-ce que plus le temps va passer plus
il va le devenir et donc plus son
premier ministre pourra prendre du poids
vous voyez ce que je veux dire h en tout
cas ce qui me semble en en écoutant là
ce qui vient d'être dit c'est que pour
l'année 2024 on peut pas dire qu'il y
ait de très grands textes qui
s'annoncent en tout cas pas à la hauteur
de ceux que nous avons vécu cette année
avec la réforme des retraites et tout
récemment le le la loi sur l'immigration
euh peut-être CELI sur la fin de vie et
celui qui qui pourrait certainement
provoquer le plus de débat et le plus de
remou dans la société qui devra être
pris de manière très délicate on sait
notamment que le le le une grande partie
de des professions médicales sont assez
remonté contre une potentielle légalis
de l'ethanasie donc il va falloir
naviguer de manière de manière fine sur
ce texte pour le reste il me semble que
les événements marquants de cette année
seront plutôt les élections européennes
et les Jeux Olympiques donc c'est
là-dessus que le premier ministre va
devoir aussi faire ses preuves sur les
Jeux Olympiques en terme de sécurité et
de logistique avant tout hein on sait
que c'est les premières attentes pour
lesquell la France doit être au
rendez-vous et pour les élections
européennes que d'ailleurs les Français
ignorent encore dans une très large
mesure sur pour lesquels il ne sera pas
trop de plusieurs figures pour porter
une autre voie que celle du
rassemblement national qui aujourd'hui
donnait largement et sur l'équilibre
institutionnel je repose ce qui était ma
question vous vous vous vous le voyez se
évolué au fil des mois ce qui est
certain c'est que là si Gabriel atthal
arrive à Matignon on aurait quand même
une un un équilibre des des des poids
enfin des poids politiques qui seraient
très différents et ce serait assez
inédit depuis que Emmanuel Macron et
notre président donc comment est-ce que
ce jeu pourra se jouer on sait que
Gabriel Atal a toujours été d'une
loyauté parfaite à l'égard de celui qui
auquel comme il l'a dit lui-même il doit
tout en politique donc ça ça conta je
pense que on a on n pas le souvenir
d'une seule d'une seule tension dont les
médias se seraient fait l'écho entre eux
on a l'impression que l'entente est
quand même assez assez parfaite est-ce
que malgré tout il arrivera à imprimer
sa marque sa ligne avec un parlement qui
est quand même à couteau tiré ça va
être nos confrères de l'Agence France
Press qui sont particulièrement prudents
et on leur fait en général vraiment
confiance dis selon des sources proches
de l'exécutif manuel Macron devrait ils
sont au conditionnel nommeré le jeune
ministre de l'Éducation Gabriel natal à
à à Matignon voilà où on en est à
18h39 dans dans dans notre émission Jean
gar je vous pose la même question sur le
le est-ce qu'on n'est pas quand même en
train de
vivre le le le le dernier souffle de
cette 5e République on s'éloigne de plus
en plus de ce quiétait le l'esprit de
cette constitution quand même certes
certes même si en réalité si vous
regardez j'ai fait un livre sur ce sujet
Élisée contre matimou si vous regardez
l'évolution de ces relation vous
apercevez que très très vite le
périmètre du du Premier ministre dès
l'époque de de georgees Pompidou a
commencé à se restrain mais mais disons
que les choses incontestablement sont
accélérées depuis la présidence de
Nicolas Sarkozi et singulièrement dans
cette présidence de d'Emmanuel Macron
c'est un équilibre très très fragile le
le le Premier ministre doit être
quelqu'un qui ne plombe pas le le le le
quinquena ou le le septena le président
de la République il ne peut pas avoir
une taux de de d'impopularité aussi
forte que qu'éisabeth borne par exemple
mais en même temps ne doit pas être trop
populaire pour ne pas faire d'ombre au
président de la République dans le cas
de figure qui qui qui qui va être le le
notre maintenant on a un président qui
ne vise pas sa réélection donc
acceptera-t-il que pour s'acer ça nous
ça nous ça nous surprendrait quand ça
n'est pas forcément dans son tempérament
ce n'est pas ce qu'on ce qu'on peut
attendre ce serait une très bonne
nouvelle pour la démocratie que de voir
un premier ministre reprendre
véritablement une partie en tout cas de
son de son pouvoir de de direction de la
politique gouvernementale et et de ce
fait devenir véritablement ce qu'il a
perdu le chef d'une majorité
parlementaire avec évidemment cette
difficulté dans le contexte actuel que
cette majorité elle n'est que relative
les mêmes causes pouvant produire les
mêmes effets Mathieu souquier sur la
capacité d'un Gabriel Atal on reste en
conditionnel à cette heure a finalement
redonné du poids au Premier ministre
dans cet équilibre institutionnel alors
je sais pas si j'y crois je ne sais même
pas dans quelle mesure je suis pas
totalement d'accord avec Jean là-dessus
dans quelle mesure c'est notre intérêt
la singularité de la séquence est moins
d'ordre institutionnel que d'ordre
strictement politique se pose dès à
présent pour Emmanuel Macron la question
de son bilan et la question de son
héritage précisément il est le premier à
dans la fonction ne pas être en capacité
de se représenter dans 3 ans et donc
dans 3 ans se posera la question de
savoir ce que le pays retient de 10
années de présidence d'Emmanuel Macron
jusqu'à présent le cœur de son bilan
cétait censé être le retour du plein
emploi ou quasiment le retour du plein
employ et de ce point de vue-là il a
effectivement engrangé un certain nombre
de résultats le chômage a
significativement reculé mais là on voit
bien que le chômage commence d'arrêter
de reculer c'est dire que le chômage
remonte imaginons qu'il remonte encore
un peu pendant quelques mois ou les TR
années qui lui restent je ne sais pas ce
qu'il reste du bilan d'Emmanuel Macron
quant à l'héritage d'Emmanuel Macron la
deuxième singularité de cette séquence
politique c'est que pour la première
fois de notre histoire politique récente
l'extrême droite se rapproche
dangereusement du pouvoir si dans 3 ans
le chômage a remonté et si dans 3 ans
précisément Emmanuel Macron rend les
clés de l'Élysée à l'extrême droite je
pense que son bilan sera durablement et
même éternellement entaché donc je pense
que il n'a non seulement pas intérêt à
replier les Gaules et à laisser son
premier ministre aux affaires je pense
que il a intérêt à réfléchir à la
meilleure organisation pour que les
forces de son premier ministre viennent
s'additionner à ses propres forces pour
nous éviter précisément un triste bilan
et un dramatique héritage merci beaucoup
merci euh à tous les trois d'avoir euh
participer à ce premier débat je vous
dis à bientôt sur sur Public Sénat et
Jean gar je rappelle le titre de votre
livre jours heureux quand les Français
rêvait ensemble publié aux éditions euh
Paillot